why should I wash all right welcome
everyone I want to thank BAFTA for
having us here tonight to chat about all
things Tennant oh yes I'm looking to
attendant now David I think you're in
richard ii right now yes ma'am
yes Shakespeare I know I think it
probably is the hottest ticket in town
right now that doesn't have Hamilton
printed on it uh and I know this because
actually right talking to the one your
tips that I can frame it yeah yeah I'm
trying to buy tickets and it's
impossible do you have to it's $500 and
more in some cases on sir take your
lucky quite right to here how dare they
not even any rap battles in this yeah I
think they need to add that I'm
delighted I guess the first question
though is this a king george's ultimate
revenge though that you're coming over
here in matching hamilton on sale
hahahaha
well yes maybe i don't know it's a no
it's lovely that you know it is four
hundred years after Shakespeare died
that we can we can create a bit of a
fuss a bit of a hubbub I'm quite pleased
yeah I mean it has what's been the most
gratifying part of the response you've
heard from people coming to see the show
I mean do do you get a chance to talk
with him after what's what does move
them what's just been lovely the
audience's here are so warm and so sort
of connected to it and cuz you don't
know you know you don't know how how
America will respond do ya but I I think
they probably respond more warmly than
the UK do to be honest and no it's been
it we've had an incredibly warm
reception and an enthusiastic one and em
a sense that people are so hungry for
for for the ROC to come here to bring
these plays and I'm just very thrilled
to be part of it really deserves start
with Shakespeare I think in terms of
your career because I mean it's the
cornerstone of modern drama as well so
we should start maybe with Shakespeare
um I always like to think about what the
first Shakespeare performance was for
you that connected for me I know the
first time I saw Midsummer Night's Dream
I was about eight years old at a
production in Stratford is a Stratford
Shakespeare Festival and that was the
one we're really connected with me right
do you have a seminal performance like
that for yeah for me it was it was a
theatre company called
theatre Glasgow
or tag as they were known as Gotland and
they came around our school I don't know
what age I was I would have been I was
secondary school or high school and so I
must have been 13 maybe 14 something
like that and they came and they set up
in our gym hall and they did a
production of as you like it and I
remember being in transpire and being
particularly entranced by the guy that
played touchdown which I just seemed
really cool and bike elite as a
coincidence that that became the first
professional Sheikh spear role that I
played at the RSC some 20 years ago
I'm impossibly young there's obviously
clear there's clearly been something
said in a dating issue I think the thing
that for me connected when I saw that
particular performance was the fit of
the physicality that because I obviously
ought not not on the language register
with me always but I could get was being
said because of how they were moving and
and and and the physical nature that for
sure but there's something I think
there's also something about that
language that connects with you on a
slightly fundamental level you don't
necessarily understand what it means but
that's why I would always see you it's
best if your first experience of
Shakespeare is seeing it in performance
because that's what it's meant to be you
know he didn't write them down to be
studied dryly in a classroom he wrote
them down to be performed and and and
there's something about the way he he
puts words together that we just that
you receive them on many different
levels you receive them sort of
poetically you receive them
intellectually and you just can't
receive them in your gut somehow when
it's good obviously when it's bad it's a
long tedious name the theater but but
when it works it I think it does I think
it connects I think it's it's sort of
fire something in you right
is that something when you first start
studying acting when you move from from
just being a fan to being an actor with
physicality one of the first things the
lessons that you had to sort of a master
to begin with oh god you're getting
dangerously close to asking me about
process which is a terrifying thing
because then of course it's such acting
such a difficult thing to talk about
unpick immediately you sound like some
self-indulgent wanker I mean so quickly
it's so hard because it is a slightly
nebulous thing and you sort of even
knowing when you've even when you think
you've got it right you sometimes watch
something back and go what you're
thinking it's it's only just it's all
kind of it's tissue-thin really isn't it
you're hitting getting the moments right
and it's so difficult to grab a which is
my long way around saying I don't really
know I don't I was yes at drama school
we certainly did movement classes we did
we did the things that drama students do
we went to zoos and watched animals and
we tried to become the essence of
aluminium or whatever it was we were
doing that day which I see quite
flippantly and a lot of it is terrible
nonsense but it's it's all about sort of
freeing you up it's about allowing you
to make those kind of connections that
don't meet not necessarly make
intellectual sense so that you you just
allow yourself to kind of your your
brain to fire in a in a in a perhaps a
nonlinear way because I think that's
where the real sort of you there's a
place for studying text and for
understanding things and that's that's
very much part of what you need to do or
what I need to do but then there's
another bit it's quite hard to kind of
define and sometimes something physical
can unlock that or sometimes it can just
be a sort of weird association in your
head it can be a color it can be a song
a you know it's a told it's just a bit
hard to unpick I find very hard to talk
about
yeah there's advance like listening you
just ask well answer this made me rather
nervous because by definition you're
supposed to come up with some sort of
insight as to what the process of acting
is or
or how you do it and I have no idea or
sense certainly no idea how to
communicate that to anybody else without
sounding like a total wanker I use that
phrase in America no but you know what I
mean right
I think he comes across yeah I don't the
I like we said about a Shakespeare Envy
the first time is to really experience
it performed is is there a difference I
mean for example uh performing at live
versus performing on camera as you've
had one performance tape film with
Hamlet
richard has Mia but for people who
aren't lucky enough to see it in at BAM
for example if they were to somehow
watch a tape performance later is that
will they still get the the same
experience how is it different it's game
one live experience is you're always
gonna be different to an experience on
screen but but different doesn't mean
better necessarily you know they're just
different ways of experiencing those
stories and there are some great
examples of Shakespeare on screen which
I think absolutely bring those plays to
life you know the Baz Luhrmann Romy and
Julia is a perfect thing to show to kids
in class show them that before you start
you know going through a line by line
and it's yeah I think you're reported
referring to Hamlet which we did on
stage and then right and then we we
filmed for the BBC that was a slightly
bit of a hybrid I suppose because the
production had been envisaged for stage
and then we kind of stripped it back and
we we absolutely did play it for the
camera and that was that was interesting
having having done something for 100
performances or whatever and then then
trying to rediscover it for a lens
that's they are rather than audience and
so there but with the benefit of sort of
knowing it inside out by then that was
that was a real treat actually because
usually when you're filming something
it's quite on the hoof you know you're
rehearsing your recording Europe you're
doing as you go so it was lovely to have
those words kind of in your bones and to
and then to try and sell it for a camera
it was a real luxury just the RSC now
I'm with train delayed do they think
about camera training for Shakespeare
because there's so many different ways
to see
now for the RSC doesn't I mean drama
schools do but the the RSC it's about
it's about performance on stage although
they now do this thing called live from
Stratford which is which is one of those
link ups where you can go to your local
cinema all over the world
and see either live or as live and we
did that bridge at the second was that
was the first production that did that
but they now do that with all the main
stage Shakespeare productions and that's
another way of experiencing I I was a
bit dubious about those events there was
the National Theatre started doing them
quite a few years ago now and I never
thought it would really work until I
went to see one I saw Coriolanus the Tom
Hiddleston Coriolanus which was from the
Donmar and Theatre in London I saw in in
there on Vancouver Island very far away
and I thought and I had some friends at
it I thought well I can't get to see
that I'll go on go along it was a bit of
a duty call but there's something
there's something electric about it
because even if it's not quite live
because you're a your honor you're in a
different time zone
it still feels absolutely like it's
happening in front of you and it's it's
a it it could be got a weird hybrid of
the sort of the live event and the
cinema event but actually it the to sort
of combine and create something rather
extraordinary with added close-ups it's
great so if you've never been to one of
those I recommend a look at your sort of
local our host cinema is probably and
showing these RSC productions or
national theater productions and and
it's an exciting
it's an exciting event to be part of
horrible to be a performer terrifying
because it's terrifying enough on stage
but to think that this is this has been
binned around the world and then any
fluff you made any blob of spittle that
sticks on your chin is gonna be is gonna
be witnessed on Vancouver Island it's
all over yeah in terms of the difference
early did you learn the difference
between acting for stage and acting for
screen what was the sort of process of
do you think of them as different
mediums and do they do calculated
performances yeah they're different that
if they require very different things
you know the quite different types of
energy
obviously if you're in the theater it's
about it's about very concentrated
bursts of energy for sort of three hours
from 7:30
whereas filming something is about it's
about choosing those moments within
within a day which can which can be very
stop start which is a lot of waiting
around and it's about sort of it's about
finding Europe and a groove and it's
also about it filming something is about
getting that movement once truthfully
vividly at the moment when the lighting
works and they everyone remembers their
lines and just that one take that's all
you need you just need the one killer
take whereas in the theater it's about
recreating sort of emotional journey
every night so the yeah they're very
definite ones about sort of you have to
talk loudly and one you don't yes
there's a lot as practical
considerations as well so see yeah
they're there they're different although
they're still there did one informs the
other as well III like I love that I've
been very fortunate to have the variety
have been able to do a bit of both and
there's there's there I'm sure that it
was the type of actor you are the type
of choices you make you know you always
sort of you're always learning I suppose
so so working in all those different
types of storytelling form is very
informative I think are there plans to
do a similar with Hamlet something with
Richard ii where you tape it and what we
did the the live link up is now on DVD
so that is that gets made available so
it yet it's not quite the same as hammer
which was very much done for cam right
it's it's it's a it's a record of what
happened in that theater that night
right but done you know with with with a
proper camera regen and angles and
close-ups and all that sort of stuff so
yes it was that's that exists as a what
you're one of the one of the
heartbreaking things about theatre is
often that that it exists in that moment
and then it's gone forever yeah that's
wonderful if you're in the audience that
night but necessary and it's not the
same to watch it on a DVD afterwards but
at least there's a there's a sense of
what that production was in a record
over and
I imagine that maybe of passing interest
to future rich person's now you've done
Richard a second here you have Emmett
are we going to see you in a comedy on
these shores anytime soon as well as
Experian I don't know this is my the
first time I've done it I've done a play
in in on American soil and I'm rather
encouraged by the audience that's right
very happy to come back to me right well
I just I think if you and Catherine Tate
did Taming of the Shrew you would sell
out not only band that possibly you know
like every single theater in Broadway so
well yeah I'm asking for the royalties
now but sure okay well when you pitch
that idea to her yeah well negotiate
okay perfect great uh in addition to
theater me you came of age at a really
interesting time for British television
as well what what sort of things did you
grow up watching we know Doctor Who and
we'll get to that but what sort of what
sort of things were informed your your
your young viewing yes I'd certainly I
love Doctor Who I loved I loved that
sort of fancy world I loved I loved The
Incredible Hulk
mmm which was an eventual week seven was
a big it was a big one for me as a kid I
don't know how much that's travel over
the USA but that was a sort of the
Magnificent Seven in space done on a BBC
but yeah sounds amazing wasn't a match
so yes as much as as a kid particularly
things like that and I also watched a
lot of comedies I love to sit calm and
even sitcoms that I didn't particularly
find funny I said loved the form of it I
love the I suppose the kind of that kind
of half-hour format the kind of the the
broad characters maybe and so yes I
would watch any sitcom the game on and
still do still love that that form and
yes I loved funny I loved you know
people that made me laugh I still I
still marvel I still think they're you
know
that's a real gift people who can really
make you laugh people who can really
sort of access that that sort of well
someone like hadn t you know it's it's
an amazing gift I feel like you were
fortunate to be I mean it's it's in
American TV now too that television
isn't necessarily a place where you go
when you can't find anything else to do
it seems like at that time they were
doing such great creative things on TV
that you were able to see and so when
you started acting you realized that
that was a forum that you could find
really interesting work to do I wasn't
just a oh yeah I mean TVs where the good
stuff is these days really it was almost
too much of it there's too much good
stuff you know we're all aware of
debates you have with your friends going
but yeah give us five seasons of that
and you've really got to start at the
first one and you can have to make these
calculations in your head and why I
don't know if I've got I don't have
enough hours in my life to do that I
might just go with that new one that
started because that because I can begin
from the start on that I'm not very good
at picking things up I've got I'm a bit
anal about it I need to see things from
the beginning and I need to say yes you
get very passionate about those tools
that you invest that time in and and
that rewards you with those that sort of
that long journey you go on with the
character I love it I mean I love it as
a consumer and I love being part of
those shoes definitely what were some of
the things you learned in your first TV
roles that you didn't maybe learn when
you were studying theatre and oh I don't
know how it works at my drama school we
didn't really do any there was no TV
training at all other was there was sort
of some but it was very old fashioned
multi-camera Canada doesn't really
happen anymore
- no I remember sort of learning on the
hoof I remember bluffing a lot the first
and I only did like tiny little bits of
TV first you know a couple of days here
and a couple days there and I remember
sort of looking around and thinking okay
I'll just try and figure out how this
worked I didn't I didn't understand that
you you short scene in different ways
let me explain that timing so that there
would be a white shot and then a
close-up and then they'd reversal your
shoulder on your clothes of someone else
and and nobody explains it so you just
kind of as it's going on you just sort
of think oh I see oh and then they'll
also then they cut that together then
they cut from there - oh I see I sort of
put it together in my head
because I did my first better TV even
before I went to drama school I did some
when I was 16
I really didn't know what I was doing
but didn't ask just sort of just sort of
pretended I knew Ludacris they must have
all known that I was terribly green
Nanterre but yes I sort of learned on
the hoof really Stella I'm still thinks
about lenses and stuff I'm still going
oh it's oh oh it's a oh it's a 215 okay
yes well I'll alter my performance
accordingly yeah so that's still alone
going okay so now for who obviously grew
up watching it when you first got the
call that it was going to happen what do
you remember your reaction when when he
found out it wasn't a call I was I was
in Russell T Davies his front room who
was the showrunner and he'd just
completed season one and he was he was
showing me bits of it and I thought he
was just showing me because I was
interested in because we we've been
working together on on another children
on a show called Casanova which he'd
also written and and he said go come
right I'll show you some sort of early
rough cuts are brilliant hey this would
be fun because you know this was the
return of doto they're sure that I'd
grown up with a Xindi dad Russell and so
he showed me a few bits and then he sort
of dropped the bombshell that they were
looking for someone to take over so it
was it was it sort of note the window of
me really and very odd when you've when
you've grown up with something you've
been a real proper fan of something with
posters on your wall and my granny
knitted me a long scarf
and a cricket jumper and yeah you know
and I careened around my back garden
pretending to be all sorts of different
characters extraordinary that all these
years later that should sort of come
full circle and then somebody
yeah and that somebody should be asking
me to be part of this - hadn't even been
on TV for however many years it all
seemed very unlikely it is pretty
unlikely yeah really
so it was a it was a quite surreal
out-of-body experience and it was very
exciting and then and then it was a bit
scary and I took a sort of week or so to
really think it through on Russell's
instruction because of course he'd he
didn't many ways I had the same
experience the shoe he'd grown up with
that had inspired him to become a writer
and he knew that you were going to have
a myriad responses to this you know it's
exciting and then of course there's a
reality check that you go through you oh
I have to actually turn up and do this
and not break it and not and not sort of
disappoint my eight-year-old self that's
a nice thing and and and even though dog
who had been off TV for a while
the the the amount of attention scrutiny
it was getting even before that first
season had aired you were aware that
you're coming into something that that
air if it didn't work you would have a
very public failure and that would be
quite difficult to and oh didn't even
know how the first things I'm going to
be received at that stage so you thought
I might be coming into something that
doesn't carry on you know I might I
might film this tiny scene to introduce
myself at the end of season 1 only to
find that's it you know the shortest
Turing actor in the room so there were a
lot of things to think through it a lot
of and also you don't see why was aware
that I would be surrendering a certain
amount of anonymity you know I'd enjoyed
being a jobbing actor I'd enjoyed their
happiness you know I certainly but it
wasn't something that impacted on my
life particularly and and you know i was
i was aware enough to know that it there
would be there would be my my everyday
existence would be altered by taking on
a part like this
even if it didn't work there just you
know your your face would be splashed
around enough so there were all sorts of
things to process and then and then I
did one day just wake up and think what
are you what's the debate haha it's not
really cuz you can have you can have
around the hoses thinking all the
reasons why you shouldn't do it why it's
a good way it might be a good thing and
then I just thought this is an
extraordinary opportunity need to work
with an extraordinary writer on a show
that you love what's the debate so when
I when I had that sort of fair moment of
enlightenment it was there was no
turning back your eight-year-old one out
in the air he was always going to win
point yeah yeah but you sort of you know
you don't want to give him that easy
victory in terms of the character of the
Tenth Doctor I've no hard evidence for
this I'm gonna get geeky now so I
apologized everything I like to I like
to sort of think in terms of how his
personality came about there's an
episode towards the end of Eccleston
season where he taught where the doctor
dances where we see suddenly after all
this tragedy he's been through the war
and the time war and he's been grim for
so long he has this moment at the end
where he smiles and he and he and he
breaks in this joyous grin and I feel
like that that is almost the root of the
Tenth Doctor in that moment because so
much of what you see later you have this
element of joy that that the ninth
doctor doesn't and there's still tragedy
in your character as well but it feels
like that almost as if we're going to
see the birthplace of the Tenth Doctor
that's almost to me anyway seems like a
starting point well I think I obviously
I take my cue from the script and for
more Russell rule and and I guess
looking back on it Casanova was my
audition for that part oh I didn't tell
you and and and Russell writes the two
characters quite similarly it was like
shagging in Doctor Who but they're still
that but they both have a sort of big
heartedness and I kind of they're
they're both sort of like puppies on
Springs they have a Tigger like quality
to them and there's I think Russell that
was a that was a conscious decision from
him and that was something that I
definitely responded to in the way that
he wrote it and I was very happy to to
enjoy that within the character yeah did
you have I mean because you had been a
fan for someone had you been thinking
about what your doctor would be like
since you were eight I mean if you in
your wildest dreams if I could make a
doctor this is who we'd be we've
actually not really because it choice
absurd sort of because the shoe had
ceased to exist it wasn't something I
spent a lot of time thinking through
because it never was and then it came
back and the part went across for
excellent so you're not sort of sitting
there thinking or what what I do with
this part when it comes my week is of
course it's never going to come and and
that's part of that sort of reality
check when suddenly you've got to come
up with a take on this a version of this
that's that works for you that you can
that you can access every day you know
it's it's quite hard work doing a show
like that so you've got to you've got to
know you can be on it and that you've
got that there can be enough of you in
it that you can sort of you can dive
into it and it you can fulfill it over
many years you know you've got to it's
got to be something that that that you
can sort of reach for and that makes
sense through the kind of prism of who
you are or I suppose so that it all has
to happen a bit more I'm aware that that
there might there was a sort of pressure
to kind of come up with a thing and and
actually I remember very actively
resisting that so that that'll just
become self conscious then and it's got
to be a bit more here comes one key out
toward its goal ten and it's got to be a
bit more organic otherwise it'll just
it'll just be a bit it just will work it
look it look artificial and it won't
sort of be connected to anything so so
no I I just tried to respond to the
script and sort of through energy at it
and see what stuck you mentioned joining
something larger than yourself when you
sign on to Hue and certainly we just saw
this past week in it a convention
comment convention here in New York with
someone proposing in front of you and
Matt Smith
yeah user to join this huge larger
community I mean as that Ben has how is
that been for you sort of realizing that
you are part of something larger all a
me it's lovely to be to be so associated
with something that means so much to
people you know it would it was
cherished not to be very kind of humbled
by that actually and and I understand it
because as a kid it meant that to me you
know it was it was something that I got
so much joy of and that really sort of
transported
not my imagination I get it and I get
why it means so much to people and this
is way that Harry Potter means so much
to some people it does there's something
about that type of genre that sort of
transports you in a way that's that's
that's got a real joy to it there's got
a none cynical nature to it which is
which is yes it's lovely to be
associated to them with that you know I
think you've also I mean from going from
joining part of that larger fandom to
creating I think your own phantom with
broadchurch which is sort of tracted a
really positive strong fan base for a
show that's very dark
yeah opposite of what happened - yeah I
mean is that been gratifying to sort of
watch that build a show like that from
the ground up and being part of that
instead of joining something a screen
yeah it's lovely that it connected in
the way that it did I mean when we were
making it we were all we got sort of
each script as we went we didn't know
where it was going and and and as each
script arrived and as we went moved
through the shooting of the season
people got more and more excited to know
what would come next we were we were
having the experience that that you then
hope the kind of the nation and the
world is going to follow it but you
never know so yeah very very gratifying
that people had the same experience that
we did and it's a state you know it's
it's a it's a great bear writing and and
then what he did the second season was
so clever and so unexpected and so an
equally kind of a edge-of-your-seat kind
of thrilling and so hoping manages with
season three yeah hopefully he's giving
you something there's something you know
to expect have you gotten any not
seclude nothing all too quick all right
no I thought there was a press release
the other day I learned all sorts
yeah I I learned I don't who's in it
with me I learnt that what what the
story's about no I know as much as
everyone in this room possibly less
you did have the experience of bringing
it over here and doing a version of it
here on GracePoint
what did you learn about the difference
between American and British television
that experience was that I think about
learning anything about that it's that
there's not enough of a difference
anymore I mean I think that's ultimately
a positive thing I think it's what did
for GracePoint though is is that we were
in a world where broadchurch had been
had already been a sort of international
thing
and with Greece when we set out very
consciously to tell the same story
because that you know someone did the
math or the math sorry and and said well
you know there's an enormous nation here
0.2 percent of whom have seen this
British ooh let's tell on that story but
actually it had sort of gone wider than
that and and and probably because Greeks
Point was really well made with some
fantastic actors I was really proud of
it and then but it just didn't get the
kind of traction I think because
broadchurch already filled that space
probably yeah because actually you know
the process of making it the same you
know it's the same sort of people in the
same sort of departments around the
world and everyone's trying everyone
loves their job and just trying really
hard and to do the best they can so and
I don't think it was a reflection on the
show that GracePoint wasn't perceived as
the success that broadchurch was because
it was it was really well made it was
just that that I think we know dramas
now go out internationally even if they
don't officially they do go out
internationally and and it's something I
think the broadcaster's are running to
catch up with you know if something
premieres in one country get it on in
the other country straightaway right
yeah because that's what you know that's
how we all expect to receive things now
it's why you know Netflix has got it so
they've just hit a moment and they've
got it so right and so we all watch
house of cards around the world together
you know and it's a it's it's just part
of the evolving nature of our industry I
guess although even in house of cards
this case that's a remake of a British
so they just wait it's not they forgot a
completely different shoe at Ashura has
its own identity it's like what the
office did you know it the first episode
is recognizably the same as the British
you and then it's a whole other shoe
equally Gloria
right but very different shoe you know
and I think that's a yeah I think that's
probably how we need to like reuse those
formats know if indeed that's what we do
now I know you're not just saying nice
things by Netflix because you work for
them on Jessica Jones but well let's
keep saying nice things about them
because what we want them to bring you
back some house we should because my
years free subscription runs out about
so if they want to send another one of
those lovely cards they gave us on day
one of Jessica Jones I'd be very
grateful but of joining the world of one
fandom was enough with Doctor Who
suddenly you're in the Marvel fandom and
that's a whole other kettle of fish and
super powerful fish but when you signed
on for it was part of the attraction the
idea of doing a villain after after
doing the the hero's response eats it
okay so I mean I you know I did what
they asked me to do it wasn't like they
said
did you want to play do you wanna be
Jessica here yeah I know they came to me
with with a project on with the par and
and it seemed like a really good idea
you know and there and it was Marvel
Comics who I love you know I always have
done so it's very exciting to be part of
and also hard not to aware that they are
the sort of biggest entertainment
franchise in the world you know and
Marvel Netflix together were clearly the
coming trend so there was lots of things
in its favor but but ultimately just
good this is this is an amazing
character with an extraordinary set of
given circumstances and the script are
really well written of course I'm gonna
want to do that yeah when you upset me
had something of a costume with a purple
suit do you wish you'd had a super
villain costume and that well I did for
a but the firt about hearing what
they're all and then finally catching up
with with the showrunner and the exact
to sort of talk it through I did have a
couple days of thinking I have painted
purple
it's not gonna get really boring by
weather
am I going to destroy pillow case after
pillow case ah it was very quickly a
boot out of my mind that that was going
to it wouldn't really fit the world of
Jessica Jones it's a very sort of real
world superhero shoe and very gritty
it's very adult very I don't don't let
your kids watch it yeah so it so it yeah
I suppose it was net that was never
going to really be the way that they
would portray that that character but
there's lots of nods to as you say yeah
I think we got through every purple suit
on see a Manahan yeah it was decided I
would never wear the same suit twice so
that set the costume department quite a
task and yeah no I mean I suppose that
became something of a costume but yes I
think I think probably being spared the
purple makeup everything's ultimately a
blessing I think not to get back to the
dreaded process part I know how much you
hate talking about that but through all
the different roles you've played I mean
is there one sort of foundational piece
of advice you see at the very beginning
of your career that sort of stuck with
you and has helped inform the different
roles you've done I - I don't know
really cuz every job is a different a
different set of challenges and there
are more sort of you know there are if
I've been giving you advice it's it's
more practical it's about you know there
are too many of us you're not special as
you'd like to think you are so be on
time turn up learn your lines be nice
don't make a fuss get on with it which I
think it may be simplistic but is advice
that many actual should take
just cuz you know most uh and to be
honest most actors do and there's a
there's a sort of myth actors are sort
of rather precious and rather difficult
and occasionally that's true mostly it's
not because mostly you actors have come
up through the ranks and realize that
it's that it's tough and that there
aren't enough jobs and that there are
too many of us and that we're very very
lucky to get to be getting paid to do
something that we would probably do for
free
don't tell the Union so you know most
people recognize that and I'll just you
know and therefore you and people work
hard because they want to because we
enjoy what we do and we want to do it as
well as we can and and yeah the other
stuff is just sort of guessing away one
of my favorite roles that you've done
isn't even on camera it's the narrator
on 2012 and dominus yeah which are yeah
the commentaries there so have what's
the secret to be a good narrator well on
that particular show which is
brilliantly written by John Norton and
everything's written by John one it
looks improvised that you it's not it
every moment is scripted every every
almond air is scripted and every non
sequitur in the narration is is
brilliantly crafted by John so the only
note he gives me is do lace it's just to
be as flat as possible to be as because
as soon as you start selling the jokes
it falls apart it's it's so beautiful
eternally crafted that you and so yes I
just I just want more I've done it I've
done the narration from from New York
I've done it from Vancouver Island I've
got it
so usually I've got John in my ear he's
quite deadpan himself and I'll sort of
do lining up you're trying to be funny
stop being funny a little bit of a joke
there so I baked him soda baking soda a
very strict keys dot at all but but yes
that's that if there's a secret to that
it's do lace always doing because that
that's what makes it funny the fact that
nobody and that she was aware they're
being funny looting the narrator if you
could narrate what's going on right now
what do you think well I would I would
hate
thank what was we said about tenant is
talking like a wanker all his effort not
to be self-indulgent of feelings yeah I
don't think yeah it's probably as well
that we're don't we're not going there
yeah I want to do a quick deathmatch
game for you terms of your characters
I'm going to pit I'm gonna pit some of
you our characters against other
characters who are in the same
profession I want to tell you tell me
you to tell me is this like epic Rap
Battles almost but you tell me who you
think would triumph in this in this in
these matchups okay Sheen epic Rap
Battles I I have not I feel bad about
the crowd probably has yeah they are
some clever guys yeah I will go home
Google min 100 okay alright see now I
ever mean I know anyone but my heart I
played is in one I'm very pride
excellent all right well this was it
hopefully it'll be as fun but maybe now
if not all Google and learn for next
time alright first time in the doctor
vs. doctor category right let's pit the
place is gonna be dangerous
let's pit the Tenth Doctor against dr.
Doug Ross from ER the Clooney character
what it's what's the criteria though is
it who's better with a lady who's better
at changing a kid man who's better we
get the wrong reasons the Democrats he's
better all those things and I found and
thank him for it and oh I just watch it
Clooney he's gotta be good
even without the TARDIS even with you
well I don't know what again I don't
know what the criteria that's true if
it's like saving the universe in some
kind of for some kind of I don't know
invasion of Daleks and yeah then then
he's just a guy who's objects are on the
doctors
ah but if it's for smoldering he went
okay there we go alright a grizzled cop
vs. grizzled cop Alec hardy from
broadchurch vs. Jane Tennison from prime
suspect I wouldn't I wouldn't be air to
up against Jane Tennison
ha-ah yeah any kind of battle Alex Hart
would give oh he's not very you know
he's a fragile soul so uh whereas I
think I think I think Jane Tennison is
pretty tenacious so cheaply when that
one too narrator vs narrator as we were
just talking about uh you uh either as
you as your character versus Morgan
Freeman okay everyone I can win give me
a chance I would give you the edge so
that's one's I'm giving you the chance
here you're excited but I think we all
know the winner of ours all right well
this one I think supervillain versus
supervillain kilgrave versus Donald
Trump well the thing is what was
extraordinary but kilgrave was he had
the most extraordinary super super power
and just used it for selfish means he
wasn't really now you could argue this
evil
um no but he just you know he he he
wasn't interested in taking over the
world so you could say that
Donald's ambition brother Trump skills
waves Trump Trump's yeah I mean yeah I
mean let's I don't think he has mind
control he's clearly doing something
yeah um I'm gonna give kilgrave that one
I just got a few mock receipt
all right let's turn to the audience for
some questions does anyone have any
raise your hands off right there all
right yeah yeah that's right
Andre Tchaikovsky well just quickly for
anyone who doesn't know on the on the
first day of rehearsals for Hamlet we
did sort of introducing each other
talking about the play time with the
history of the play and then towards the
end of the day Greg Doron a director got
this box out and he said I'm not going
to introduce you to the final cast
member we were like what's he talking
about
and he opened this box put on these
gloves and lifted out a human skull
which was the skull of a concert pianist
Andre Tchaikovsky whose dying wish was
to play Yorick in a production of Hamlet
and he donated his head to the Royal
Shakespeare Company and nobody had
touched it it had been there oh I can't
remember how many years now I used to I
used to know the fact it'd been there
for a number of years and and there'd
been several production of Hamlet and
nobody wanted to go there
I'm Greg Greg did and I was thrilled
actually because thrilled for Andre we
got who got his dying wish but also it
makes that scene where Hamlet picks up
the skull and and looks into the eyes of
of someone he knew it makes it all the
more poignant when you're thinking I'm
this is actually about mortality this is
not some actor standing here with a
plastic probe this actually connects to
another human being who who aspire in a
way aspired to be here as well you know
they seemed a bit so that it worked on
several levels there was just a sort of
glory that he was onstage at the Royal
Shakespeare Theatre and but but in terms
of what it did to that scene alas poor
Yorick alas poor Andre this is you know
this is what we become this is it
this is what that scene is it's about
the fact that ultimately we are we are
matter and we can we can imaginative ly
fly through the universe but it come
down to a lump a bone and that and
that's what's the core of much of
Shakespeare's writing but certainly the
core of Hamlet you know what a piece of
work is a man that's it
so um it was it was very moving
actually it to be to to be able to bring
Andre on stage and to be able to look
him in the eye every night it was it was
a it was a wonderful thing and I'm
thrilled we did it
anyone else I directed a drama school
group sparked my course why are you
laughing it might have been brilliant
you didn't see it and I directed drama
school and I do have I'd like to try it
yes they would have to be the right
thing and I've had a couple of close
calls I suspected my out at some point
but it was have to be something that
sort of connected them I don't think I'm
a I'm a director who could turn my hand
to anything but but certain things that
that I feel like I get I'd like to have
a go out but no immediate plans oh yeah
that's when it uh well Shakespeare
clearly uh you know yeah when when the
work when you have to when you have to
raise your game to match the word you
know you're in it you're in something
that's juicy and when you're sort of
Toni I'm going how do I make this sound
like a human being you know that's
that's not the right way right so yet
Shakespeare wonderful clearly that you
when you can get on top of those words
and they take a bit of a grapple because
they are four hundred years old and they
don't all immediately make sense but but
when you get can I get inside them
it's like jazz so yeah Russell T gave us
I would I would do anything he wrote
ever and I've been so lucky Chris
Chibnall and Tony Marcin and oh my
goodness I've been very lucky actually
with but and then I sort of in terms of
dead people and Tennessee Williams I
loved doing his words Eugene O'Neill I'd
love to do some Arthur Miller I never
have and there's something extraordinary
Tom Stoppard that sort of almost beyond
all our intellectual capabilities ah oh
my goodness oh I I just went to see
Kenny Loggins Kenneth Lauren's us play I
did a play of his he reminded me 1914
years ago which test doesn't work the
man I'm only 26 and you know someone who
writes words like that you know where
it's just ah delicious so many I mean I
could yeah but good writing is what you
seek out it's it's what makes your job
exciting
I think unfortunate all the time we have
time for tonight but I will chess can
you like whose just warming up and
you're young as we know you can go all
night after all this but no we have to
call it for now hahaha that's what's up
next
yes but there's one last thing yes this
is very kind did someone just never be
something 11 again it's very Joyce yeah
very much you can all have a piece how
did job to come to you I have an agent
who friends me up and send the scripts
through to my door and then I go into
the auditions and chat to people and
play scenes and see what happens to keep
your hand in is important i that's
easier said than done
but erm if you can get together it
sounds sort of ridiculous but where's
like-minded mates and stick something on
camera even if no one's going to see it
just keep loving it
you